[Musique]
est-ce qu'il vous est déjà arrivé dans
les restaurants et de ne pas finir tout
votre assiette qu'on vous avez compris
je suis serveurs reytier la sas y est à
moitié plein de la table des clients les
vider dans l'espace dans le sac poubelle
c'est ma grande déception
je vous laisse imaginer à la fin de la
journée
le poids et la dimension de ce sac c'est
la dure depuis plus de dix ans et pas
seulement dans les récents je suis dans
des bars discothèques événement public
jeté de la nourriture à la poubelle à
mon sens c'est un gros manque de respect
à bord vers toutes les personnes qui
travaillent derrière
commençons par le fermier qui doit se
plier sur son dos
à côté les produits de la terre et ses
produits sont transportés jusqu'au
restaurant et le vendeur les laissera
dans les mains du chef et le chef
commence avec ses mains à se mettre à
l'oeuvre à travailler pour nous à nous
préparer un plat plein d'amour donnera
directement dans les mains du de
serveurs dans mes mains elles s'avèrent
par tous contents avec cette assiette
laisse à la table de du client et s'il
est que si l'assiette n'est pas finie
s'arrête souvent serveur doit reprendre
la ce est allé le vide est dans le sac
poubelle et du sac poubelle d'être
transportée jusqu'à la déchetterie et
rend même des conséquences pour notre
planète
mais par contre
si toutes là c était fini le cycle
s'arrête là car ces clashs 100% naturel
moi comme serveur qu'est ce que je peux
faire pour que tout cela ne se produit
pas pour éviter de que tout ça se passe
les nouveaux clients quand tu arrives au
restaurant n'ont pas lieu d'être au
clair la quantité de nourriture qui sera
servi dans leur assiette
par contre moi oui je le sais en
travaillant dans le restaurant je
connais les blacks je vends et en plus
je vous dis que nous le serveur nous
avons une alarme dans la tête
c'est une alarme qui sonne quand un
client est en train de commander trop
j'ai commencé à utiliser cette alarme
pour proposer à certains clients de
prendre aux plus petites portions à la
place d'une grande
effectivement les lectures acceptent mes
conseils
saad vraiment quelques quelques secondes
il s'agit de poser une question plus est
ce que vous voulez que je la fasse plus
petit
justement les clients acceptent l
assiette reviennent à la cuisine
complètement vide
ça c'est le début de mon action contre
le gaspillage alimentaire
après quelques mois de pratique sur
cette démarche de conseil
je trouvais qu'il était important de
mesurer ce que je faisais
j'ai alors commencé à travailler j'ai
alors commencé à travailler seront
formule pour avoir des chiffres et
chaque soirée à la fin de service j'ai
commencé à baiser les sacs poubelles à
l'aide d'un crochet qui j'ai réalisé
avec un ami en utilisant en bien centre
en balance pour les bagages je voulais
ramener est là
je tremble un peu
non c'est bon il me fallait quelque
chose de très simple et très rapide
utilisé parce qu'à la fin de service la
seule chose que vous faire ça nettoyer
compter l'argent et partir donc commencé
à ceux qui lisent comme le service est
finie la plus basse est ferme
je la soulève une fois fait l'onu je
prends le bois
après quelques semaines un vrai casse
tête de recherche formule feuilles
déchirées
j'ai trouvé la bonne formule je prends
ce poids je le multiplie par mille et je
divise par la chiffre d'affaires que la
manière plus simple pour connaître
combien de travail
certains jours c'est chose qui le boss
regarde tous les jours en fin de la
journée et leurs droits il se sent c'est
ce qui les intéresse donc elle est là
la résultat de cette formule c'est ta
ratio le ratio de taux de gaspillage en
termes de chiffres je suis faire
l'exemple fin de la journée je paie sa
poubelle
il ya 11 kg 40 je multiplie par mille je
divise par 7300 francs en 60
si par contre on aurait travaillé on a
relevé la même quantité de travail
mais un arrêt j'étais moins de
nourriture de la poubelle le sac on
était plus léger et par exemple car la
place dans ce qui donne on avait il y en
avait neuf et nuit
voyez le ratio baisse donc mon gaspille
plus ce ratio baisse la restaurant
devrait se mesurer régulièrement essayer
de réduire le plus possible le retour de
l'esprit âge
cette inutile qu'on peut utiliser par
exemple comme je me montre ici on est en
comparaison les résultats de tous les
jours sur une semaine et déduire des
petites choses qu'est ce que je vois ici
le mercredi et le samedi
j'ai les pics je gaspille plus que les
autres jours plus que ma moyenne
pourquoi je m'interroge à l'heure
mercredi 1 décembre pas l'école c'est la
journée des enfants et la salle pleine
gamin peut-être que ils commandent leurs
plats ils n'arrivent pas à le finir
ou peut-être alors je peux je peux
réduire les portions qui sert aux
enfants ont peut-être que je pourrai
leur servir quelque chose qui
mangeraient pas inquiet et les samedis
mais samedi c'est le jour où les gens
sortent avec leurs amis ils discutent du
bab leurs mains et qu'on essaie de
parler avec eux teaser c'est pas facile
à tout cas en communication claire les
samedis ya beaucoup de bruit peut-être
en d'améliorer le travail de conseil à
l'heure c'est juste des exemples
l'idéal serait que tous les
établissements mettent à disposition des
petites portions pour permettre aux
serveurs de les conseiller à certains
clients ayez un moment de la commande en
décision responsable
quand je parle de cette idée à mes amis
et mon entourage
ils disent toujours la même chose elle
vend des petites portions restaurant ne
convient pas ils vont perdre de l'argent
je vous en mets un exemple parce que je
pense que vous aussi vous êtes posé la
question si on prend quatre portions
mais normal des grandes qui on demandera
25 francs on a facturé son frein et j'ai
appris avec mon expérience que souvent
les gens qui mangent pas beaucoup
laissent un quart de leur assiette
alors on barre à dire ces quatre
portions de un quart avant mettre les
ingrédients du côté alors maintenant on
a quatre petites portions qui on
demandera comme disent les clients
petite torsion petit prix d'accord on
enlève quelques francs c'est juste par
exemple ici on les vendra à 22 francs ça
va donc on a ces quatre petites portions
plus les ingrédients qu'on a mis du côté
qui sont l'équivalent de une portion
normal si on additionne le tout ça donne
113 francs donc c'est par magie mais les
plus productifs de vendre des petites
portions à celui qui mange moi et en
plus nous laissant la place à cette
personne de prendre un dessert il
m'arrive de voir des gens qui laissent
la matière de leur assiette pour laisser
la place pour un dessert ça m'arrive
souvent comme je voyais que cette
stratégie était assez simple
à mettre en pratique facile à diffuser
je me suis je me suis dit pourquoi pas
lancer une initiative visant à
sensibiliser d'autres équipes
j'ai décidé d'aller personnellement dans
chaque restaurant et parler avec les
serveurs pour toucher leur conscience
pour qu'ils puissent faire la même chose
avec leurs clients mais si je le fais
personnellement c'est parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes tous exposés
à différents messages publicitaires qui
n'ont pas toujours un effet fiables sur
notre comportement mais seulement les
émotions contenues dans le langage d'un
humain à humain peuvent avoir un impact
sur le comportement des gens on arrive à
sensibiliser les restaurateurs les
serveurs et leurs clients sur ce
sujet-là apporterait un impact très
positif sur la réduction du gaspillage
alimentaire
aujourd'hui je peux vous assurer qu
avant de faire un choix ne devrait en
ralentir un moment réfléchir posées aux
questions de plus haut nous poser vos
questions de plus pour prendre une
décision responsable parce que nous
sommes les responsables de notre avenir
et de l'avenir de notre planète
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]